we recently got a chance to test out the
battlefield 1 closed alpha and I spent
most of my time playing as a scout for
veterans of the Battlefield franchise
this class shouldn't be a far cry from
what you've come to expect but there are
some key differences
as most good scouts you want to be well
scouting this means surveying an area
marking enemies and backing up your team
from a distance if things get hairy the
only map in the Alpha is Saint Quentin
scar and lucky for you this French
countryside is a haven for snipers a
basic rule of thumb is to stick to the
edges of the map this makes you less of
a target for enemies but it also gives
you the best field of view that is you
won't need to constantly be rotating to
cover the entire battlefield glancing up
hills and around buildings at the center
of town
but of course rules are made to be
broken obviously there's no one good
spot that will give you a good Vantage
of every objective but there are
certainly plenty of good places to snipe
from I would avoid towers and win meals
because that tends to be the first place
most people look and whether someone is
in one of these are not people like to
watch them collapse so instead let's
stick to more unassuming buildings for
now
one in particular that I found to be
effective is located near C from here
you can cover three objectives and there
seems to be no shortage of targets
wandering around in the open if you
don't think you can hit a target from
here make sure to mark them for your
teammates another area that worked
pretty well for me was the hill right
above e it doesn't take too long for
this hillside to get cratered up from
artillery and heavy weapons so camp out
in a crater and you should have some
decent cover and a nice view of the town
a lot of people like to hide behind this
door so keep an eye on that it's also
worth mentioning that for some reason
shooting through doors and windows
hasn't been all that effective as a
scout now it's time to pick a weapon in
the Alpha we had access to three sniper
rifles each with two variations to be
frank there really isn't a huge
difference between these rifles the
Russian 1895 is a lever-action rifle and
the Gewehr and smle are bolt-action
rifles
all three of these rifles have similar
fire rights and can deal quite a bit of
damage
the biggest difference however between
these weapons are the effective range in
battlefield 1 snipers have a sweet spot
if you hit someone at a certain range it
will do extra damage it's also worth
noting that just like previous games
you'll have to take bullet travel time
and bullet drop into account although
judging from the snipers I used bullet
drop was pretty minimal
I rarely had to compensate for it
lastly let's take a look at the
equipment unfortunately Scouts only have
access to two gadgets in the Alpha but
let's start with the flare gun
you only have one flare so make sure to
use it sparingly when you fire it
enemies should light up in that
direction on your mini-map during my
time I did not find the flare gun all
that useful but it does deal fire damage
which is kind of cool the other gadget
are anti armor rounds you can load into
your rifle called K rounds the range for
these aren't too far but if you're at
the right distance it can deal a little
bit of damage I found it best to use
these on vehicles that were already
disabled or some of the smaller quicker
vehicles
as with any class you'll develop your
own methods the more you play as Scout
but these are just a few of the
fundamental differences and tips that
should get you started once you get
behind that scope if you enjoyed this
video and you're itching for more
battlefield one content make sure to
LIKE and subscribe down below
you